to discuss the war in Gaza I'm joined by
the Palestinian ambassador to the UK
usam zlet Ambassador thank you very much
indeed for coming in I do appreciate you
taking the time particularly at a time
like this to to come to the studio you
were very active on Twitter from the
moment that this hospital was uh hit you
said it's a massacre hundreds are killed
in an Israeli strike uh on the hospital
hundreds of medical staff taking Refuge
how long will it take to stop these
atrocious war crimes you then say
waitting for UK government condemnation
of this atrocious Act of mass murder
after being directly hit by an Israeli
air strike and you Carri it on when Kia
starma uh said the scenes of hundreds
killed at the hospital in Gaza are
devastating can't be justified
international law must be upheld but
didn't mention Israel you said why can't
you condemn this why is it so Harvest
someone with a background and human
rights law is it because the victims are
Palestinian so you were in No Doubt
last night this was an Israeli air
strike and yet I watched the BBC News
this evening they did an extensive
investigation of everything that's
available at the moment by their verify
unit specifically designed to cut
through any partisan rhetoric and get to
reality and based on circumstantial
evidence as they said but the the clear
conclusion of that investigation is it's
far more probable that this was actually
fired from within Gaza it was a misfire
and it landed in the car park to the
hospital and they site for example the
the crater is Tiny by comparison to the
kind of crater you would see from a
conventional Israel missile uh and so on
what is your response to that have you
changed your absolute conviction that
this is an Israeli air
strike before I answer your question Pi
um today is the first day of our
national morning for uh the killing of
hundreds of innocent
people and in in memory of those
hundreds of doctors nurses medical staff
patients cancer
patients uh uh patients with kidney
failures
children innocent people who took refuge
in a Baptist sponsored Hospital the
Anglican in memory of all of those who
were
killed last night allow me to have a
moment of
silence
now back to your
question this very same
Hospital the
Baptist ahly Hospital of Gaza was
bombarded only two days before last
night by the Israeli air strike and they
recognize that this very same Hospital
was designated by Israel as a place to
be evacuated this very same Hospital the
director of it was called by the Israeli
occupation authorities asking him to
evacuate all patients on mass but that's
not my question no no no that's no no
I'm I'm I'm answering your question and
allow me to answer my question is are
you still as sure as you were last night
I'm I'm answering I'm answering your
question I believe the Archbishop of
Jerusalem when he condemns the Israeli
air strike I don't believe the Israeli
mouthpieces and spokes people they lie
more than they breathe and this is their
record is very clear number number three
number three you think groups in Gaza
have
such you know uh uh precision and
Firepower really I don't think it was
precise the point if you look at you
look at Ambassador with respect you look
at the BBC you look at the BBC
investigation it was they include
footage which seems to show a rocket
misfiring let's have a look let t a
it there's no
sound you see it you see it go up and
then you see a ball of fire and it looks
like and this was the BBC's conclusion
based again on circumstantial evidence
that this was fired from within Gaza it
misfired it then landed in the car park
next to the hospital now all I ask you
this Ambassador yes I am an ambassador
I'm an official and I tell you with
certainty this was an Israeli air strike
where's your evidence I have the
evidence and you will see the where is
it I'll tell you what's my evidence my
evidence is that we are calling for the
Red Cross to come and investigate this
and for the IC and until now the Red
Cross has the responsibility at such war
crimes who's who's blocking the the the
the Red Cross anyway we have very strong
Civil Society human rights organizations
on the ground we are communicating with
them tomorrow you will hear from
everybody and you believe you will
produce evidence isra we have yes we
will yes we will why would the American
question ask don't ask me about the the
Americans the Americans why would the
president of the United States say that
his own independent investigation by his
own people I not the not the
intelligence given to him by the
Israelis that has also established it
came from within Gaza is that a serious
question P really you think the
Americans are you think he's lying
President Biden yes he is lying he is
lying and he is part of that's a big
charge to make about well he has he has
just lied before getting any evidence
there is no way such seen I don't know
if he's seen evidence what he said he he
doesn't have Personnel if he has
Personnel he must Pro provide protection
for our civilians then he is complicit
and the crimes against when you see that
video what do you think you're what do
you think you're saying it's
whitewashing and gaslighting as we have
been seeing over WR and uh well what if
I am wrong bring me again here okay
bring me again here and then we'll
discuss it no one has such Firepower
except the Israeli but have you seen
theat have you seen the crater Army and
you know what no one even in the region
has such
Firepower very sophisticated have you
seen the crater I have seen I have B I
have does that crater not tell you it
was not an Israeli air this is the trick
I'll tell you what happened Israel did
it Israel thought the world was giving
it the green light that it was okay to
do so but when we did it they did not
expect the outcry and then they did it
again as they do all the time why is the
crater so as they as they do all the
time they simply go out and deny it blur
the lines two stories we don't know and
I will remind you few weeks from now or
few months Israel will come out and
admit it but it will be too late they
will not get the I don't think they I
don't think they will they will they
will admit it as they did in the past in
the past they have denied many things
and have you seen out of Interest have
you seen the BBC verify investigation I
did you watch that tonight you know the
BBC is is is to be blamed for part of
this because the BBC just run one day
before that Hamas Di digs tunnels
underneath hospitals primarily speaking
instigating the Israeli IDE of another
another indication that they did it that
they should go after hospitals which is
a war crime as you know very well
defined now where is the issue here what
is the main issue here is that all these
lines that have been happening over the
years are not challenged by you pierce
you and all the mainstream that's
completely untrue no no it is true all
that says to me is you never you've
never seen me on Earth I have seen you I
have seen your interview me years I have
seen your intervie you seen me interview
net I I I have seen your interview just
a few days ago with Israeli Ambassador
she did say here on this seat on this
seat that they provided the whole south
of Gaza as a safe Zone and they are
building shelters to Palestinian
civilians she told you that and I said
did you challenge her I said though did
you challenge her I challenged her like
this no you did not challenge her you
did not challenge her me tell you s I
tell you my sister he denied there was a
humanitarian crisis I said there was no
no you didn't yes I did no you didn't
yes I did you started you started that
conversation with her with showing and
outpouring emotions good for you about
the mothers why didn't you start with me
about the thousands of mothers
grandmothers literally read that
literally with me Ambassador this is the
asymmetry this is the asass that she
lied she lied with you and she said that
the south of Gaza is safe you know how
many people were killed in the south of
Gaza only in the last 48 hours you know
that my sister now she lives in the
south of Gaza and I you're following my
Twitter look at my nephew Amar you saw
Amar you saw what happened to Amar they
live in the south so an Israeli official
sits here and tells the world that the
Gaza the south of Gaza is safe and
people should go there on mass therefore
ethnically cleansing these people to the
to the South to actually actually
slaughter them and then you pierce do
not look her in the eye and tell her
stop lying I was on the BBC Sunday
morning just a couple of days ago
uh with the foreign secretary and others
before me was another Israeli mouthpiece
spokes person Mark re he said we did not
and will not Target any hospitals they
lie all the time but just to be clear on
the hospital there is a
clear circumstantial set of evidence
which has been established now by the
BBC by the independent verify unit they
don't have any skin you think that was
the first time Israel targets a hospital
pece no I'm not saying I'm just talking
about last night's atrocity which is
what it is because hundreds of people
have died there remains a massive
question mark over whether Israel had
anything to do with it what about the
other 2,800 well let me come to this all
right what about the other let let's
let's come to this so I want to take you
back to October the 7th because you were
very quick last night when you believed
it was an Israeli air strike that had
committed this horror which had killed
several hundred people we're not
entirely sure of the exact death toll
yet but certainly hundreds of people
appear to have Di died you were very
quick to demand that everyone from K
starma to others publicly condemn what
had happened of course so let me take
you back hang on let me take you back to
October the 7th this no no I'm not
playing anything don't play this don't
play this if you are in the no I wanted
what I wanted let me my question okay I
know where you're going but I want to
explain I don't think it takes a genius
to work out where I'm going but let me
ask a question first then you can
respond please okay okay my question is
this you're very very keen to demand
that political leaders in including saki
starm here publicly condemn yes an
attack on a hospital which may not have
been Israel right and you repeated that
throughout your your evening on Twitter
right that's true but what you have are
not prepared to do yourself as the
ambassador to the UK because I've
checked your Twitter feed and you've not
done this and to my knowledge you've not
done this in public you're not prepared
to condemn Hamas for the slaughter of
1,400 innocent people in Israel on
October the 7th so I give you the the
chance given that you want others to
condemn acts that kill people even if
they're not responsible given that Hamas
brazenly admitted responsibility for
what they did are you prepared to
condemn it you you know this game and
this narrative it's a game it's a g it's
a game it's a game I'll tell you why
should you demand
condemnation of people dying not be
prepared to me to explain it to you and
to your viewers why it is a game and a
very vicious unfair asymmetric game that
has contributed to the oppression of my
people for 100 years number one you know
our position you know that Hamas is just
a militant group that was created 20 30
years AG is the
terrorist you asked me this question
okay what is the definition of terrorism
I'll just ask you think the definition
of terrorism I'll give you I'll give you
the the UK government I'll give you the
prescri give I'll give you the the def
the international United Nation
definition of terrorism it is the
unlawful use of viol against civilians
to terrorize them for the sake of a
political agenda agreed
agreed unlawful violence against
civilians do you and answer me please
well no I've asked do you consider do
you consider Israel to be a ambassador
to be with respect I'm asking a
terrorist state do you consider Israel
to be a terrorist state if you if you
won't answer me why should I answer you
did we agree did we agree on the
definition of terrorism I I've asked you
isass a terror Israel has been targeting
civilians in front of your eyes for 7
why should I answer any of your question
you answer mine deliberate targeting and
not just this this round 2014 you know
all that happened 25 I'm very aware of
the history then you very critical of is
is Israel a terrorist state I'm asking
you the question is Israel a terrorist
state ambassador this is the asymmet
answer me and I'll answer you about you
it's not how this works it's my show
you're a GU it is from now on this is
the way
there has to be Equity you are the
ambassador to the United king we are
I'll ask you a question I'll ask you a
question you are the amass I am proudly
so proudly so I I'll ask you a question
and you've been here I think since 2018
you've been Ambassador for 5 years right
yes and I was in the US before right and
the UK government has Hamas identified
as a prescribed terror group do you
agree with that that's that's the UK
business you don't agree no no no the
this is not about me agreeing or
agreeing I'd like the the UK to
designate the kahanist the Israeli
government as a terrorist group you may
want other groups as a terrorist group I
want to see as thean Ambassador do youe
to see with Hamas being prescribed as a
get my point please get my point I want
to see equal treatment and I will accept
the equal rules if these rules are
applied on the the on the Israelis I
would raise my hand and accept I will
put my hand on my heart let me say this
to you do you consider Israel to be a
terrorist let me say this to you that's
number one number two I'll ask you do
you accept the UK you ask me about the
UK government theuk UK designates
Palestine as the occupied Palestinian
territory right opt we are occupied do
you accept that design well it's an
interesting question about occation
isn't it that's your government I think
the Palestinians have lived in a very
repressive so it's not occupation well
it's it's a repression right what it's a
they are living don't accept
International they are living as
oppressed people I I have I have for
years oppressed by what well they're
oppressed by by Israel effectively
keeping people trapped in Gaza right and
they have the ability as they've shown
him the last few days to turn on and off
water to turn on and off food supply I
think all this is wrong what about what
about those Bank Ambassador I think it's
all wrong but let me just ask no no this
is a major point it's you're not
intervie me is it is it an occupation
Ambassador you're not interviewing me
what you're trying to do if if you don't
mind me saying you are distracting from
my original question it's a composition
respectfully Ambassador it's a convos I
was interested that you last night were
demanding that political leaders like K
starma condemn a a supposed attack by
Israelis on a hospital which now looks
like it wasn't by Israelis and I'm
simply saying to you keep repeating this
this how youor let me finish my question
how do you know it's not
by how do you know I don't so don't say
it but nor do you I am I know what I'm
saying I represent the situation you do
not know it was an Israeli you hold me
accountable next time you're neutral
you're neutral I am neutral I'm not
neutral okay I get that so no no no you
are being biased that is honest you are
taking the side no I'm not you are I'm
not saying you are following the queue
from isra no I'm not okay I'm saying the
BB verify unit has said tonight I think
do you think they're impartial in this
or not they shouldn't this is they won't
even call Hamas terrorist this is none
of their business this is the business
of Karim Khan the prosecutor I'm going
to ask you one more time and you don't
have to answer this question if you
don't want to it's entirely down to you
but given that you last night you wanted
people to condemn what happened last
night in your belief that it was Israeli
air strike and you were ferocious in
demanding that repeatedly will you now
take the opportunity to condemn what
Hamas did in October the 7th final I I
only ask you one more time 22 Arab
states convened at the beginning of this
including my state my government and
they condemned do you personally condemn
it they condemned the killing of
civilians from all sides you know what
is not all sides from all sides do you
condemn what happened October why you so
reluctant to you asked you asked you
were the one last night demanding people
I'll I'll tell you I would be the first
to condemn if I ever saw you asking an
Israeli official to condemn did you ask
the assador to condemn all the
atrocities I will be asking I'll I will
be asking a representative of the
ambassad you had the Ambassador before
me you did not ask her to condemn
anything then you didn't watch the
interview I did yeah I did okay let me
ask you one more time I did because I'm
not sure if you heard my question I will
not answer this question unless you
allow me to explain no no that's fine
you don't have to answer it no no no
I'll tell you but if you're not going to
answer it don't demand that other people
condemn things and certainly don't ask
me to condemn things if you won't
condemn 1400 people being our position
our position how can you not condem what
they did our position is very clear I
represent the Palestinian leadership and
people I represent the PLO that's the
sole legitimate represent representation
of the Palestinian people president
Mahmud Abbas the government Hamas is not
part I know of the government okay
that's number one number two that
legitimate representation I represent
have committed for 30 years for first
nonviolence and negotiations I belong to
that camp you're you're asking the wrong
person committed to International
resolutions and committed to the
recognition of Israel we recognize the
state of Israel long before anyone else
and we still waiting for Israel's
recognition of us and guess what
happened in this 30 years every
political Avenue was blocked every legal
Avenue like the icj and the ICC is
blocked every hope for any Palestinian
is blocked you are talking to a person
who religiously believe in non violence
so please don't ask me that question if
answer this way why
you you believe in nonviolence that's
why I Pi why you so reluctant why I want
to become an ter believe in the power I
believe in the power of diplomacy I
believe in the power of nonviolence I
believe that we should always return and
maintain the moral High ground but
that's why I am answering the way I'm
answering that's why I'm challenging you
because because the moment I accept your
question is a moment I accept we are the
instigators of violence we are the
aggressors and I asked you the question
before she didn't say that no no no I
didn't say that I understand you're not
part of Hamas no no no no no not me not
me only the entire Palestinian people
are the instigator understand you're not
the question I understand you're not H
let me explain Pierce please but
understand cool down cool down the
moment I accept this logic of
condemnation in the lack of Israeli
officials being asked by you and
everybody else to condemn that moment I
accept that my people are lesser of a
people that we are not equal that we are
lesser of a you know children of God and
I don't believe that okay no I I think
and I think I think no I think
Palestinian people are absolutely
entitled to fairness and equality and
human rights many of the things they've
been deprived of for decades I would
love to see peace in the Middle East but
nobody can show me how what Hamas in
October the 7 has done anything for the
Palestinian people other than set
everything back and make peace even more
unlikely the moment I see that Equity
that balance you I'll be the first to
use any word you want but so long as
there is this imbalance this racism
against Palestinians this consideration
of us of being of being you know 1if but
racist against Palestinian no no I think
there are people who are racist I think
anti-palestinian ism is flourishing
everywhere I think we are seen as to be
less of value than the Israeli lives
I'll tell you how I'll tell you why I'll
tell you why you brought me here you're
bringing everybody this has been the
focus of everyone you have located your
moral compass on the 7th of October no
no did you locate your did you locate
your moral compass say to me did you
locate your moral compass 200 people
killed this year in the Westbank did you
bring me to the many Palestinians who
were killed only in the last few months
this is the that's resp to I've been a
journalist for 30 years I've run major
national newspapers I had a Daily Show
at CNN for four years if you actually go
back and look at what I did including
for example a 2-year campaign against
the Iraq War which I thought was an
illegal invasion of a Middle Eastern
country so please do not pigeonhole me
as somebody that has no compassion
Palestinian people no don't generalize
you you oppos the war I've been getting
Palestinians on all week I've been
giving Palestinians platforms including
you all week right but when Israelis
were harmed you see this is what I'm
telling you why didn't you be
Palestinians when hundreds thousands of
Palestinians killed by settler militias
K Ambassador here's my answer I can
guarantee you absolutely guarantee you
that if the Israelis ever carried out a
terror attack of the nature we saw on
October the 7th they are doing well they
they kill 1948 they pulled Holocaust
Survivors out of out of their homes and
kept them hostage they shot babies in
their in their crib watch the
terminology they burned families alive
deliberately going in to get civilians
you see you see you see your
responsibility is to really use the the
right terminology why this is all of the
world that happened you you are invoking
many things here you've just invoked
terrorism you are now invoking Isis you
don't dispute it as a terror attack you
are now invoking Isis and you spoke
about I hav mentioned Isis but for the
record not with you but for the record I
do believe there's a parallel between
what Hamas is done on October the 7th
and Isis no that's that no no no I'm
okay you see you don't agree the
Israeli what happened on the 7th of
October is not condoned we reject
wholeheartedly the target of civilians
our culture our upbringing who we are as
Palestinian Christian and Muslims what
happened is nonp Palestinian how is that
and we reject it and we want to continue
maintaining the moral grounds of our
cause very right let me ask you this
okay okay let me let me continue let me
continue okay
okay however since the
7th of October this the first moment
Israel started preparing and putting
together a huge campaign to delegitimize
the Palestinian people to link Hamas to
Isis and then link Hamas to the
Palestinian people then link the
Palestinian people to Isis then do the
ethnic cleansing and the mass
destruction and the mass murder you are
following on your okay that's exactly
what happened then the international
media mainstream media were literally
following the cues following the cues
Isis you you you talked about Iraq all
the time Isis is a group of criminals
who gathered from all over mercenaries
who were there to kill and only to With
No Agenda you agree you think
Palestinians are that don't you think we
have a political Cas to make so why are
we using this term we are using these
terms to allow the isra war machine to
kill Mass resp that's why we are using
let me respond so everybody who use
these words is complient resp Ambassador
let me respond everyone let me respond
okay respond please I do not believe
that most Palestinian people support
what Hamas did on October the 7th I do
not believe you do I do not believe the
Palestinian Authority does so do not
think for a moment that I think you're
all the same I think Hamas is a terror
group who committed an act of
unspeakable depravity and terrorism and
they must be held accountable the
question is what is an acceptable way to
hold them accountable I do not believe a
full ground Invasion will do anything
but make this 10 times worse for the
record but let me ask you this there are
200 hostages I think 199 hostages been
kept by Hamas should they be released
they they include children they include
Holocaust Survivors what is your view
yeah all hostages should should be
released first of all they should be
keep safe and protected and they should
be released but hostages from all sides
how do we get to Poli here question we
have five we have 5,000 hostages in
Israeli jail also including children and
women we have many of them who are
rounded there without charge or Tri
everybody has to be released I've got to
wrap this the final
question how do we get to peace from
here it seems to me after 30 years of
covering this conflict we've never been
further away from peace between Israel
and Palestine how do we get to peace
here by
listening from your heart and your brain
that this is a people struggle for 106
years 106 years because it all started
here the B for declaration by the
British Empire where they promised our
land without consulting us and they
turned Us in that 67 words into
non-jewish
minorities we were 98% of the population
we had lived there for Millenia we were
the cardal of civilization we produced
every Prophet Palestine is the
birthplace of Christianity we were
literally The Hub of the region the
linkage between Europe Asia and Africa
and all of a sudden we are only a
non-jewish minorities and then Britain
took over our land and not only they
denied our people's hood and Nation Hood
in 1917 but they denied US during the
mandate our statehood because the the
the contract with the league of nation
was Britain will come and take Mandate
of Palestine to prepare us and to
recognize us as a state as Palestine you
know what happened in the nakba and the
mass expulsion the the Jewish militias
at the time ethnically cleans 2third of
our nation including I know the history
including my own parents so I know the
history I have great Sympathy by the way
with what happened since then my people
67 and the military occupation that we
discussed since then then this is a
people's struggle for freedom for
justice for equality this is a people's
cry to survive how do we get to peace
this uh uh by by full application of
international rules we did not create
the post World War II two State solution
yes of course Israel has to end its
occupation that began in 1967 Refugee
Rights must be respected in accordance
with International uh law two neighborly
countries can get into together with
neighborly uh relations but the
Palestinian people have the right to Def
defense defend themselves and a state we
don't have an army a state has an army a
state will do so so occupation is the
root cause of all this discussion I have
to end it there we've had half an hour I
appreciate you coming in thank you very
much I understand the passion as you say
you're not you know you're not an
impartial person in this I understand
that and I wish your family all the very
best in Gaza I really I mean that very
sincerely thank you I hope they're okay
thank you thank you for coming
in